We have here Rylee Miller.
He's a law student
at Drake University and a clerk
in the Marion County Attorney's office.
He's a Republican
who is currently undecided. Riley,
thank you.
On the debate stage,
you have somewhat of abandoned
the tact and diplomacy
that I would look for in a president.
I'm all for
keeping it real
and dogging the establishment.
But there's gravitas and
that I look for
and those who represent our country.
How do you see the balance between
keeping it
being authentic and maintaining
that presidential demeanor?
I appreciate the question.
I think it's very candid.
This is what I love about Iowa.
I get tougher questions from
you guys than I do from the media.
That's and that's good.
That's why we're here.
So I appreciate that. Look,
here's the standard I used
for holding myself to
or holding any president to.
I want us to be able
to look our kids in the eye and tell them
that I want you to grow up
and be like him.
It's been a long time
since we've held our presidents
to that standard.
That's the standard.
I want you to hold me to.
That's a high standard.
Now, I think about that
in judging the way
that I comport myself in different areas.
Am I going to tell my kids
to go to school and be a bully?
No, I'm not.
But I'm going to tell them
if somebody bullies you or hits
you, you're going to hit them back
ten times harder.
And that's the way
I'm going to lead this country.
You can't
you have to be, as we say in our family,
you have to be strong enough
to protect your kindness.
So if you watch those debates carefully,
I don't engage in four letter words.
I mean, there are other
candidates have called me
dumb scum and worse
that I'm not going to repeat here.
I didn't go after them.
But if they're going to come after me,
I'm not going to be president.
Whether it's Xi Jinping or Vladimir Putin
or anybody else
who's going to roll over
when I'm leading the United States,
the same rule applies.
If you hit us, we hit you back
ten times harder.
But it's not for the sake
of being a bully.
It's for protecting our inner
kindness, too.
And I think it's important
that we have a president
that has both of those attributes.
I've done more podcasts probably than
probably than most
presidential candidates in history
combined, mostly
because podcasts are new.
I'll admit that.
But I will tell you,
that's a different setting.
And so I believe
I think it's the book of Ecclesiastes
that teaches and my faith
teaches me the same thing.
There's a time and place for everything.
There's a time and place for fortitude.
There's a time and place for justice.
There's a time and place for mercy.
And I think it's going to
take all of those attributes,
every last ounce
of each of those attributes
to stand for this country,
to reunite this country
and revive who we are.
You don't want a wilting flower
in the White House,
but you also want
somebody who understands
what we are fighting for.
That's the standard
I want you to hold us to.
We will aspire to hold ourselves to.
And I think that sometimes
being a parent is
what gives me my moral clarity.
And I hope
through the rest of this campaign
we're just getting warmed up.
I hope to be able to earn your trust
that, yes, I do have what it takes.
To tell you the truth,
I'm not going to hide the truth from you.
You want
someone is going to speak truth to power.
Vote for somebody who's
going to speak the truth
to you, to the Republican Party.
Do it unvarnished without sugarcoating.
And I don't do much sugarcoating.
But also somebody who is you,
I believe one can stand for the ideals
that would make our founding
fathers proud
and would make our children
proud as well.
Speaking Speaking of those debates,
let me ask you about something
that you said at the debate last week.
You use the phrase inside job
to describe what happened on January six.
The next day,
Capitol rioter Alan Hostetter
highlighted your comments
at his sentencing.
He is going to prison for 11 years.
How Hostetter
threatened members of Congress.
He brought a hatchet,
knives, pepper spray,
stun batons, tactical gear to the U.S.
Capitol.
Are you concerned that
a convicted felon like
that is now
promoting your comments in court?
So here's my concern, Abby,
and I want to tell you guys where I'm at.
If you had told me
it's close to three years ago
that January six, 2021, happened,
if you'd told me three years ago,
back when I was a biotech CEO,
not steeped in this world,
I was just consuming
passive media,
but was focused on
my world of developing medicines.
If you had told me that January six
was in any way
an inside job,
the subject of government entrapment,
I would have told you that was crazy talk
fringe conspiracy theory nonsense.
I can
tell you now, having gone somewhat
deep in this, it's not
I mean, the reality is this
We do have a government
first of all, we have to acknowledge
that has lied to us
systematically over
the last several years
about the origin of COVID 19,
about the Hunter Biden laptop
that we were told was false
by 51
CIA experts and otherwise
before we now know that it was true.
You can go straight down the list
that Trump-Russia disinformation
collusion hoax, all of it.
Now we come to January 6th.
The reality is
we know that there were federal
law enforcement agents in that field.
We don't know how many.
I think it's shameful.
Let me finish this answer.
Well, let me just as I'm going to
I'm going to go ahead
and interrupt you here because
because I notice
that the establishment
has approved this message.
I know there were federal
should be able to talk about.
You're saying that there were photos.
This is important to talk about this
federal agents in the pardon office
on January six.
There is no evidence
that there were federal agents
in the crowd on January six.
So why before Congress,
when pressed on what the number was,
they didn't say there were none.
They just couldn't say.
You're saying that there is no
that you have not seen any evidence.
So we've seen Mark,
and so you've seen multiple informants
suggesting that they were we know people
we know people were FBI informant.
So we're asking,
is there any evidence that may just
come back?
QUESTION Well, let me clarify.
It was very uncomfortable.
I'm going to clarify.
I know this is an uncomfortable
high people, but we have to do the truth.
I'm going to clarify my question
because I want to make sure
that you understand
I understand this deeply.
And I told you I was here three years ago
where no evidence. Yes.
Where is the evidence
that the government
had a plot, an inside job?
But no, I what inside job.
So I'm not going to I'm not violent.
On January six.
We're not going to let
you put words in my mouth.
I'm going to put my words in my mouth
and I'm going to tell you
what the evidence entrapment
was involved, entrapment,
planning or executing January 6th.
So I'm going to give you I'm
going to give you hard facts.
And if I may, Abby,
I know
this can be a little uncomfortable,
but we're going to
we're going to go through it.
And you can and you can
you can push back on the evidence
and you can push back on that.
And let's do this fairly.
Why did they suppress footage of now
what's been released,
200 hours
of footage of shooting
rubber bullets into that crowd,
shooting tear gas into that crowd?
You didn't see that before.
You saw what the response was to that.
Now you see footage
coming out of actually
rolling out the red carpet
for Capitol Police.
Mr. Ramaswamy again
right through the front door
of that credible
evidence should have been,
you know, for Mr.
Ramaswamy, the vast majority of
the footage shows
and my police officers being over
and I want to talk about one word
violence really import rioters.
That's going to get a hard story,
some hard facts of it.
So what?
Here's what entrapments cherry pick.
I'm not cherry
picking and I finish up not sure if
and I'm not sure if the samples
to the contrary to the country
the cherry pick example
you know cherry to
the government
is what the government cherry said.
12 hours of footage
when there was 200 hours of cherry
picking was the government, not me.
Release the whole thing
and let me let me
just finish one thing too,
because this is super important
as a topic.
So when you bring this a civil
libertarian issue of our time
when Russian hackers kidnaping,
I want to keep it going
to be really clear on this
because it's the same issue
in the same FBI,
same even part of the FBI.
Three people
who are in alleged plot
to kidnap Gretchen Whitmer were acquitted
at the end of trial
because it was entrapment.
That is, government agents
put them up to do something
they otherwise wouldn't have done.
They give them credit cards
with spending limits of up
to $5,000, encourage them to buy
munitions, plan
something they weren't
otherwise willing to plan.
So much so.
And I want people at home to know this,
especially CNN viewers to know
this, is that one of the jurors
went to those defendants
and apologized afterwards,
gave him a hug,
apologized seeing what the government had
put a poor guy up
to who had to go
to some Mexican restaurant
across the street to get hot water.
These people were exploited
with credit cards up to $5,000.
FBI agents
putting them up to a kidnaping plot
that we were told was true
but was entrapment.
Same thing with the Capitol Police,
people letting them on the floor.
Many of those people saying, Mr.
Comey, look,
the government cannot put you up
to something and then charge me like,
that's wrong.
I don't want to have all of it
to the left.
I don't I don't want it.
I don't want to have to interrupt you.
I really don't.
But I don't want you to mislead
the audience here.
I'm not
I think they've been misled
by mainstream media.
14 The mainstream media has misled 13.
Police were charged in that plot.
A majority of them were.
I said three of them were acquitted
on grounds of entrapment. What you what?
That's a fact.
What was I wrong about that, folks?
Was I wrong about what I said?
What I want you to understand
is that acquitted on grounds of interest
nine works.
Sure. Apologize.
Fine work. Yeah, but you said.
But the three who were put up
but never got back.
Stage January six.
That's unacceptable in the United States.
Look, I just want people to understand
three people were acquitted.
Nine people were convicted. That plot.